[Music]
[Music]
hello happy Friday hello gentlemen happy
Friday yeah
we have ran through the gamut of betas
this week culminating to today
she's monster hunter worlds final beta
before the release next week it comes
out on the 26th but if you want to check
it out it is up you can download it I
think it runs till Sunday I don't want
to say and we're just kind of going
through our inventory here changing the
equipment a little bit to job links
liking and then also trying to get a
fellow games water Ben djenka yeah into
his party so that they can hunt together
I believe they're gonna do some hunts
down the road once the game releases but
yeah thank you guys all for tuning in
I'll be in the chat so you have
questions send them my way I can kind of
point them over to John Luke who's been
playing a decent amount so he should
have some insight to help you out
I've played like 30 minutes to an hour
as of last night definitely interested I
only knew about one trick weapon that
reminds me of blood-borne but uh
apparently there's more than one so I'm
gonna have to check that weapon out too
yeah we actually can't there's a train
you can check out the training mode in
the beta which is cool yeah but now that
you're waiting but there are like 14
weapon types in this game they're all
like pretty different I would akin it to
like a blood-borne where it is more like
each weapon does feel dramatically
different mm-hmm and so I'm right now
going with the dubidouxs dual blade very
fast very speedy
I'm telling you man I have this this
inkling that he's Meryl and not Phil but
yeah the the other interesting thing is
so you hunt monsters tom games and vlogs
essentially to get crafting parts
because you don't actually get specific
loot from the monsters as much as you're
getting like pieces of the monster that
you then need to craft you know specific
armor or weapons and it's kind of like
random drop right like if you need a
Fang of like some monster you don't
always get it just because you kill it
so that's kind of yeah there's ways to
like potentially increase chances like
you can attack specific body parts
yep he is totally Marilyn told you it's
gonna cost
I believe it's $59.99 right full retail
price yeah I mean like it's a pretty big
game I think single players gonna take
you like upwards of like 30 hours
potentially before it gets to kind of
like the end game or the real game of
monster hunter right I mean not that you
wouldn't have fun playing the first 30
hours but like any buddy that's played
Monster Hunter before probably knows
that like all the like crazy Monster
Hunter stuff happens like post story for
me it is like for you you know it's not
so much but it's funny like this is the
meat the meat is coming off of these
monsters be gonna meet yeah so like
making sure you eat before you go hunt
is like a pretty big deal as complicated
as you'd think
food make sure I have enough potions
like just kind of your small little
daily rituals to make sure you have what
you need
well I think it's also cool that it's
one of those types of games that you
know has has these systems in play and
they're not too difficult but it can get
like pretty complex there's like more
stuff you can do like I was telling you
I was watching a video I was like oh
this guy's like using like these pit
trap things that's cool like I wouldn't
have thought to do that or like you know
trying to use your environment so let me
preface this I've never played a monster
hunter game before and this is your
first to use my blue monster oh yeah so
where there's a couple people that have
played of large like Merrill who is one
of been djenka in the office he's played
a bunch before and so is Justin hey Walt
I know Jason a striker loves it giant
bombs Jason a striker that's our boy oh
so I bought that guy last night and I
smoked him but but we have some gear
right that like you wouldn't start off
with
monster you encounter in the game and a
lot of the gear you're getting in the
beta right now is some gear that like
you wouldn't have later although they
actually changed the stats I was looking
at them like there are different yeah
they intentionally kind of like ours
yeah he he knocked me down once and it
was because I was just not careful and I
wasn't totally used to kind of a camera
stuff yeah but you know you kind of get
used to that as it goes the cameras
interesting because they came us a
lock-on which is the first time I guess
Moss Turner's ever had a lock-on it's
not that great I don't think it's that
great I can see that ever as I found out
like a day or two though there actually
are certain like advanced aerial moves
okay I was like why would I ever do this
it's impossible to like actually like
properly hit an enemy or lock-on and
then you do it you kind of auto target
so you actually okay so like what Ben
might be doing there yeah so there are
instances where you actually do want to
I'm sure I'm sure
yeah in those certain cases as you just
mentioned or maybe if you just get used
to it but like I was I so for me like
playing like blood-borne and Dark Souls
and stuff like that I used lock-on a lot
more than pot most people do um and so
coming to this last night I had to kind
of just be like okay I don't think this
is really working the way I need it to
so I better start learning the dislike
attack free cam
oh yeah yeah that's uh I've seen been
through that before it's just part of
the string so that's the other fun part
is as you use different weapons they
have kind of different like button
combinations that you can do different
kind of Enders the reason why I liked
the ax I think it's like the great axe
or something like that was because it
did really remind me of that blood-borne
trick weapon type thing where you know
you could do a combo with the ax you
know and then like at the scores to end
the combo you can you can trick it you
know or evolve it I think is what the
word is in this game and then I think
and then it turns into a sword and then
you can just like keep going or with a
new cut like a new combo with a sword
after like had subsequently be using
that ax combo and it does like this
crazy thing at the end which is cool
so I got to try that other I think you
said there's like a sword and shield
that turns into like an axe so another
fun-packed like so that so those things
the flash the flash flies I think like
they'll blind them right yep yeah which
is like pretty cool so you gotta learn
to use your environment exactly and then
you can get oh nice okay yeah that's the
other interesting thing is like the
range weapons there's like a bow and
arrow there's like a cut like it one or
two guns I think yeah two types of guns
and there's a bone arrow which actually
like play again with Kirk party this
beta has like one really hard monster
which I guess we'll get to at the end
the near grant a looks a intense because
the thing is like one of the end game
monsters and they only give you 15
minutes in the beta which is kind of
ridiculous
notice which acts in normal game you'll
get like 50 minutes usually apparently I
Jan's live to thank you for that
information
yeah like in the pets I kind of wish
there was like I'm sure there's like a
lower thing that makes it like make
sense that it's cats but yeah that would
like some dog there's a pig in the game
I do see the chat it's Connor sorry I
was kind of just talking because I'm
kind of excited I'm like I don't know
I'm like in between on this game only
because Dragon Ball fighters birthday so
it's like man tough go the bow okay um
HECO vanie DG we're doing pretty well i
hope you're having a good friday or you
know maybe saturday if it's saturday for
you i saw some okay so i was watching
someone last night and they were
crafting some stuff for the bow forget
what it was but man it was like one of
the attacks with the with that item was
he was getting a hundred damage yeah
which is like insane i forgot what it
was called he had to like craft it with
like fire herbs or something i don't
know it looked like an item that he had
to craft that then he would use or
something i I don't know enough about
Monster Hunter it seems like it's been
in previous monster hunters but not
codings
yes same things have coins you get these
vials and you can film with different
things and you put him on the bow and
then they'll have different properties
so there's like a Power Shot there's
paralysis sleep it's not those keep
going and that is very dependent like if
if you want to be very viable with the
the bow as a weapon you need to have a
lot of different coatings
it sounds like this beta is only on ps4
yeah this time so sorry guys I guess
that's just how it works sometimes with
exclusives or times exclusive stuff so
yeah it runs till the 22nd Monday which
till 159 a.m. UTC the main difference
with this beta compared to the other
ones is that it has that near your Gantt
a monster that we I just mentioned which
we do have gameplay but we'll also show
you guys that today yeah that's fine I
mean like it we'll use it as the you
know the the final final thing
CJ fan how are you doing sir he says the
bow is my favorite early favorite for
sure cool are you gonna be playing on
ps4 CJ or PC do they come out on the
same day
no no PC is coming out we later right
okay yeah Oh Jake Arnett asking how many
initial characters will there be in DBZ
I don't know you'll find out next week
depends to if you have the pre-order the
the Blues oh yeah that's the other thing
too right like you want to use like
aerial advantages when you can try to
mount monsters yeah do extra damn
there's some weapons I just like it let
you do that which is kind of cool I was
like watching um Justin do it I was like
oh man this is like Starship Troopers
when he's like Rico's up top on the
beetle and he's like get in that hole so
he can throw the grenade - it looks like
that's the other thing - I didn't I
didn't uh I mean like right this is like
why a new like a new Monster Hunter
thing but like I noticed when a guy
knocked down one of the monsters he had
like a large barrel and he was using the
large barrel to it like explode it on
like the monster like once he had it
staggered on the ground he put the
barrel down and like basically made like
a big bomb okay I think it's gonna maybe
try and jump on him yeah with it with a
risky
thank you Oh
Legolas out of range right there
safe bet and then another key down the
road is making sure you're like well I
don't know how it works for the bow but
like for the other weapons that they're
sharp in there yeah you don't have to do
that with the bow it's it's more about
the coating the coating
oh good dodge to dodge so I got a couple
of cool things like you can do it like a
dodge into a charged shot
Oh off-the-wall that was all [ __ ]
off-the-wall thing which is tough to do
but if you do it this way that's how
you're going like that that's a little
tough because it's very dependent on the
environment like it's kind of hard for
me to tell what item I'm able to only
any sort of flat surface
using some purple stuff Oh get flashbang
I know that the the barrels are not in
the Atomium it's just that me as a new
player to monster hunter I didn't know
you could do that so it's just like I
was trying to speak to the more layers
of the game that's right not just like
your weapon combat stuff well but thank
you for giving us that tip how many
shots does it take the skill probably a
lot that was the one thing that again as
being a non monster hunter noob it was
just weird to see all these like kind of
like low damage amounts and yeah like
you don't you don't see the health bar
what you do see is like damage on the
monsters or when they're like missing
you know animal parts or when they start
running away it's like all right phase
one is over in the little bottom next to
the mini-map you can actually see oh
yeah
and there's also like these little like
scout scout flies that will kind of like
tell you hope where you get get to where
you need to go typically you will we've
been getting lucky where he just like
shows up for us but typically you want
to like kind of be like tracking and you
get the extra points which help you
level a little bit from what I've seen
yeah and then that in the full game has
do you like so okay so it does have a
lot of benefits so like do you find
yourself like you know tracking all the
footsteps looking at like oh you know
okay cool cuz like last night I was like
yeah why wouldn't I hold circle on all
these to get like almost experience or
whatever there are like stats individual
to each monster
working set you will get you like level
up your Scout fly like knowledge of each
monster and then that will give you
benefits where like I think the highest
tier one is just you'll immediately know
where they are cool
yeah you can play solo and also you can
like you know like we would have found
other players to play with if we wanted
to earlier so close yeah this comes out
next week on Friday a a 12-4 days if you
have a Playstation and you want to try
it out before purchasing it the beta is
open and it's available for download
right now oh look at that
BAM do you actually hit it with him this
so that's the axe I was talking about
the attack yeah he tried doing the sword
ender there but I don't know if he
actually hit him with it that was a bad
time to try and do that
Oh see been gone on him yeah get on them
go got to ride him and there's like a
little like what is it you just like you
do damage but then you are also trying
to like you know stay balanced on it
yeah oh yeah drops like a bunch of like
spikes al chops or something yeah yeah
so like this is the key to it's like
once you stagger them that's when you
kind of want to get your big beeps in
yep like the Hammers got this crazy
whirlwind move like a barbarian which is
like awesome oh yeah they're gonna have
a little oh I just killed him we did my
brother revenge multiple fight here a
different monster that has just shown up
that's the awesome thing too is like
sometimes you'll see them just fight
each other yeah that's cool yeah you'll
get to like it's all very random so
you'll have these encounters where just
like a complete different monsters show
seven they start fighting each other
mmm you can kind of use that to your
advantage so cool Oh mr. nobody I mean
part of it is it Monster Hunter is kind
of just a grind I think I mean I could
be wrong about that but like there's
definitely gonna be some some crying to
it because you're trying to farm
monsters essentially to get you know
gear from our body parts from to make
your gear and you know that's part of
the game but the cool thing is the
monsters get they get different later on
Oh like they don't just do what this guy
is doing some of them will shoot like
the thing that we were just near earlier
like it shoots out mud to kind of like
slow you down and stuff like that so
yeah I mean part of it someone who just
doesn't like any sort of grind at all I
mean if you're somebody who'd like fine
there goes his tail you know if you or
somebody who liked destiny or like oh
it's a game where I can get together
with a group of friends and we have
something to play together yeah you know
oh you gotta help
yep people hold them down
Little John Madden come on John
it'll never show you the actual HP
fender claw what it does is it's like
you try to look at the monsters um body
for like the accumulated damage is taken
as you can see the tails gone I think
that it runs away as it's getting like
hurt and like you know sometimes it'll
run farther like more than one time
depending on you know how you're doing
in the fight so there's not actually an
HP bar to feel like hey it's almost dead
you'll know you can see the there's some
really rad looking like armor to like
down the road oh yeah that's that's
definitely the big appeal is every time
you beat a monster there's a whole set
of armor specifically for them we are
currently on a pro but we're just
streaming out 1080 60 Pro it has three
different options for the pro it has
prioritized resolution frame rate and
graphics I always pick frame rate which
is really really yeah so I had that
option I sent I was like I'm pretty sure
I'm going frame rate go frame rate I
don't care about the resolution I want
it to be smooth and buttery exactly I
think that's the most important thing
when it comes to a game like this yeah
with so much going on - yeah so okay so
those things I think they're called
anthills like this thing to your left I
don't know if it's that specifically but
like there you can use these things to
get them stuck well maybe not that guy
cuz he can crush it but like I saw a
video where a guy was using that and
like the guy was getting stuck and then
he could do free damage to him because
he was trying to get his head out the
whole time yeah
this is like a little sand pit he can
like fall oh really
it's a lot there's a lot of
environmental stuff do we need to tame
them sometimes you do for the missions
right and encaptured you don't like oh
look at him kind of gimping away but you
can capture some and obviously you don't
get to like I've done four parts but
then as you get more like quest reward
bonuses for it to make up for it alright
so he was trying to yeah he got me on it
so I can really do with the foe but a
lot of times you do cool tricks where
when sliding down what I do not know
what just happened
oh he jump down looked like he phased
into it all there for a second so you
also have like that little like stone
thrower thing on your wrist what does
that do other than like distract or like
okay set the monster basic form is
you're just little rock pellets Little
Rock pellets but you put other stuff so
I can put like dung on here that will
actually make monsters run away oh
really okay if you want to like get them
out of your way you don't really have
much different oh I could put like
poison knives on it yeah so someone was
saying like poison him yeah you can put
like flash pods there's all sorts of
different stuff you can put on that goal
you're using the bow wrong how so evil
calves sure tell me if I'm using the
bell wrong I don't need to vote off I'm
using it wrong please tell me uh the
review hopefully will be next week
Bob Wow that dude I gotta go that weapon
if I play man how how much does do the
weapon change as you're like crafting or
like making new ones they don't change
functionally no no visually sorry they
can change a lot like ya know some of
them are a little more subtle because
they're like multiple trees and stuff
but a couple of them are actually pretty
different looking yeah because like I
keep looking at Justin's like bone
hammer I'm like you've been playing for
a while and that thing looks the same
probably just upgrading like that's one
hammer and boring
yeah this is just like a sample size of
what you're gonna experience it's
obviously not the whole games as a
camera felt mentioned bull game
there we go he's gotta find the weak
spot the neck the jugular oh what's that
BLAP BLAP oh hey where's the guy that
said we were using the bow Rob I want to
know know I'm very curious I'm a monster
or newbie for the most part yeah we're
we're still learning me what I'm doing
wrong you're supposed to charge your
shots with the bow and not just fire
them he likes to tickle them sometimes
well if he's supposed to charge it the
damage doesn't look that different I
guess I guess he's losing out on sixteen
damage but then does he fire faster
twice than he does one charge so how do
you jump on his back so the way he's
doing is this when you slide down a hill
you can usually hit the roll button and
you'll do okay
oh that way nice hi-ho silver
I don't know if I can answer this
question popping mouth I'll defer it to
John Luke and then he can decide if he
can answer it or not but he asked does
this one have the farm hub like the
earlier Monster Hunters or is this or is
there a caravan guy that multiplies
their items for you
I've never played another monster so I'm
not circle and triangle they said hold
circle and triangle everyone wants you
to hold and charger shot yeah oh they
want me to do they want me they just
want you to do a lot of charge shot it's
cool
it can be a little tough because the
problem is zombie start doing that you
actually hit your angle too much so I a
lot of times I have it where he would
then move around and I can't Bo's have
what's known as critical distance where
your screen shakes
this will increase damage Thank You
Tyler Jackson Abhishek Sharma it is open
beta but just on ps4 runs till the 22nd
yes so that's definitely a thing about
this game is that you there are a lot of
like little tricks with each weapon that
you just kind of learn over time it's
about three or four days Thomas so you
know I'm played too much you circle the
harvest boss yeah we could harvest oh
you forgot you forgot to go up way to go
no I'm just gonna go up again do you
want me to hide it for now or we it's
fine it's fine
hopefully okay I mean there's delay so
I'm sure he'll be kind of ahead there
mister nobody have a good day enjoy
hopefully you can get in and place them
yeah they're expensive so I mentioned
there's not really a reason to carve in
the beta I mean yeah we're not trying to
go and craft anything or anything like
that someone wants to you just use the
charge blade
here
charge blade mark is there a charge
plane there probably is I'm just not
know familiar enough with like which one
it is
yeah I don't either so should be I
believe it $60 Sandesh Stankovic this is
the one I was talking about that has the
Oh gray fox saying so the game releases
on 26 yet they are having a beta test
lol it's more of a demo at this point
don't you think well I mean like they're
not gonna they can call whatever they
want I think it's actually smart it
seems like a lot more games are doing
this where they're holding these betas
before the games come out and I think
that's awesome if they're open beta is
because it gives everyone a chance to
try the game out to see if it's
something they want to play it's almost
like a like a little mini rental if you
think about it I barely use this weapon
so apologies if I don't know what I'm
doing with it that's fair out we can try
the gun Lance later there is a switch
axe puppet mouth that's what Meryl or
the character Meryl was using just now
how do you get in the beta at boy you
just have to get it go to the
PlayStation Store and then get that
Monster Hunter beta it's good for the
next what three days three days give or
take every game blade is a charge blade
alright cool fully been good sin thank
you and mb don't pc beta probably won't
be for a long time since i think it's
not coming out till I think you said
August yeah or something late sometime
later some later Xbox I don't think
they're gonna have another beta but you
know if there is one cool especially
since the game comes out next week this
progress carry over from the beta know
is just mean they basically hand like
they give you armor that you wouldn't
have just for you to mess around
the cool thing though is you can kind of
pick your weapon to start though I would
assume oh yeah notice they give you from
the Gecko they give you access to all 14
yeah and the test the test the testing
grounds for that is pretty sweet too I
think it gave me the ability to go mess
around with the weapons I do kind of
wish that there was like better targets
but yeah it's it's cool especially
because it does actually give you tells
you like some of the combos you can do
which is nice ya know beta on xbox Jason
win not this time just some PlayStation
ok a 12-4 days says I like how you have
to use a whetstone to sharpen your
weapon yeah it's pretty key cuz so
there's like a meter underneath your
health I think or maybe your health and
stamina but uh you want to make sure
when possible to make sure that it's
green so you're doing better damage it's
almost it's pretty much worth it for you
to like stop engaging in combat try to
find a safe trying to sharpen your
weapon but we are gonna join this going
to do a beginner's guide which will help
me a lot and that'll be out sometime
next week so can you play this demo
online with your friends yes dope effect
we're actually playing with one of our
coworkers so yeah as long as they have
you know have have PlayStation obviously
because you need that I'm guessing you
probably need PlayStation PSN or
PlayStation Plus or whatever to to be a
online as long as you have those two
things I don't see why not you should
definitely be able to play it's Connor
how long the stream is probably for
another hour give or take probably go
get whooped by The New Yorker ghonte at
least once
philanthropy Aki been Jenko saying the
charge blade is a heck of a time
mute that guy shitty you got a like a
breather
Santa's stink of it asking we stream any
other cool beta games that there are any
yeah we did actually a bunch this week
if you want to go back and watch them we
did Dragonball Fighters yesterday which
is also coming on this week which is
pretty cool and then the day before that
or and also yesterday not the day before
that but yesterday we also did metal
gear survive which is also in beta and
you can play that too that one is also
open beta so if you're curious about
that you can try that out too a lot of
betas going on this week gonna go play
this actually haha have fun taste see
you later CJ enjoy thanks for coming by
appreciate it I don't know if I ever saw
what your answer was the ps4 PC but I'm
gonna assume or sorry not you're not
gonna play on PC that's not gonna happen
I keep thinking I got too many games in
my head like everything PC is delayed
though right no that's not true
Dragonball I think comes out the first
day one every day yeah oh you don't need
PS plus for this demo okay
that's what l Mistico says I'll take
your word for it ya know it was the
first oh okay
any best weapons in the whole game I
mean I think it's I think they're pretty
balanced across the board I think it's
what you enjoy playing and or what's
most beneficial to your party because
there's like one weapon that straight-up
says it's a support weapon yeah it
looked really funky but yeah you
basically can like like plus your group
music to like yeah you're the bard
you're the bard man except with a
big-ass weapon ooh yeah so the sword soo
and she'll turn into an axe which is
pretty oh I know that again I haven't
really used this so I'm just kind of
going off of what I remember about it in
the tutorial when I was messing around
with all of them is that I know you want
to hit with the regular sword to fill up
meter you swap to the bigger a bigger
one yeah
like you'll swap between them and then
you can like release sort of like your
energy from it uh so let's go find the
monster yeah Andrew Smith's not hard for
me to say I've only really used one
weapon because I only played a little
bit of the beta last night John Luke's
favorite so far as dual please how do
you sharpen your blade what buttons SJ
clausal it's like a item so down there
in the audience I just bought them right
yeah what stone although I don't need to
actually do it right now because there's
also a way to put the charges in your
shield that help you block heavier
attacks right now yeah this one has all
sorts of interesting techniques of like
charging and is this like a 1 on the
like hard scale of weapons to use it's
probably one of the more complex things
because of those charge systems and
again I barely use this weapon side do
not know how to use it so apologies if
I'm not using it correctly or
efficiently Ricky Hernandez be near
gurgaon tail ese awesome cool hope you
had fun doing it no nice Oh Ben's using
that gun this game have a story mode yes
it does yes not in the beta though is
combat in this game war complex in
horizon zero dawn
about that that it's I don't think I
don't know if you can compare the two
[Music]
yeah shoot it's play yeah keep sitting
the questions over no worries well we
can do it does every weapon charge of
all I don't think so this weapon has a
lot of it there's web enough said a lot
of the systems to it that I just good I
feel like you can play this game for
hours and what's up Carlos Cruz Lee
different weapon and it's very hard to
use lol but is fun yeah I mean like it's
cool like I'm happy that there's a guns
that are worth taking that guns weapons
there's a variety of weapons you know
anywhere from like you know simple to
use it kind of complexes cool
Oh what is that a little bit of
Elemental ground slash that's pretty
sweet
he switch weapon hands or is your tuna
left yeah what's up sector avancez can't
you use demon mode demon modes for dual
blades grace it's like he sticks a
little like flare rocket into him
that Whitburn blade is pretty sweet -
those blades cool it's pretty simple to
use which I like it's like pretty quick
like the game does tell you like hey if
you're a beginner you should probably
just stick with these these ones are a
little more advanced so I want to you to
use the heavy folk that man for this
hunt that we're gonna go to came the one
I'm not sure I don't know if we can
answer that yet either even though like
we might have the answer I don't know if
I can answer that he wants to know if
the multiplayer works the same way as
this beta or if it'll actually work off
the friends list in the actual full
release of the game I can say that you
can you can invite people okay yeah I
mean like I don't think it's a big deal
it's just I I don't know the limitations
is like I haven't been though the game
does also have like a code system as
well but yes
roll around just like real real life
here stop drop and roll
whoo he's on his back get him get
stabbed
that'd be way cooler if I'd hit him yeah
well I feel like some of those attacks
like I don't know if it's just yeah you
save them for that like when you know
he's on the ground and he's gonna take
the beating no matter what I don't know
what hit you someone knew you got fired
see what that weapon or was that from
down
oh hey he lost his horn Oh nope there it
is when he's feeling frisky yes the beta
is up on PlayStation again Johnny games
if you want to go check that out and
here
when you are in a sword and shield
pressure angle and circle twice to use
your feelings Oh God it just says when
you're in sword and shield press
triangle and circle twice nice try get
me to do I'm just not sure that's the
right yeah it's hard cuz they're ranking
systems ranking system yeah there's
monster there's only but you have like a
monster ranked and that determines like
well so that does limit you a little bit
in terms of like if you're trying to
play with the friends do you know the
answer to this so fear it's the cat said
in previous games when someone gets on
the back of the monster you should stop
attacking because it would actually
shorten the ride time is that not the
case here then we'll answer that when
here's a good question I actually would
not know oh man there's a lot going on
here
oh yeah that's unfortunate I thought
maybe he would swing his head into it
a TSA and this is the kind of game that
will make me feel proud and a sense of
compliment accomplishment when I do get
good you see that struggling against
particular monster and then might
overcome it so like that mini Dark Souls
feel almost yeah I'd you like the
feeling of overcoming a boss and Dark
Souls like that's basically this entire
so how do you feel the vile I do this
weapon okay at once charge Feliz r2 plus
circle there you go okay yeah I just had
to read good thing it leaves those up
button prompts up there thank you thank
you chopping the legs we're gonna have
to do that again soon
to get your oh oh when you get that
circle was gonna do it or yeah now
that's our to encircle to charge them
okay now you're out of Iowa see
yeah yeah so the charge Khalil's as
forgotten who said that it's art to
encircle in the sword and shield motive
thing so once you morph out of that now
if you do our two-foot circle or charge
they got three there yeah mr. toxins 97
it will the full release will be on xbox
but this beta is apparently only on ps4
so sorry to the for the Xbox folks oh
okay yeah so you can do that again
probably are to circle later I would
assume no you just charged no you did it
with one earlier I'll tell you when I
see the prompt maybe you have to attack
with the sword
watch me butcher the Seabee is painful
and then don't worry Dylan Dylan was
there I picked it because I wanted yeah
we're just showing it off and it's not
something you use a lot so it's like I
think that's cool though like I said you
know to have a weapon that you know you
could on paper just use and be like
teasing that but obviously it's a more
difficult weapon to use and once you do
get like good with it
now you can do our two circle maybe you
do have to use it all we're Swede
because there's a do a clip of a dude
Sola and your garganta with the CB for
minutes and forty four then there's this
guy hey man we we are not Monster Hunter
pros this is his first Monster Hunter I
could do that people just like to it's
the Internet
welcome to the Internet to [ __ ] on oh so
that guy got got fainted right so he's
gotta get brought back over here
thank you Justin Middleton way more
entertaining than anything on ignorant
or IGN yeah
we I don't know anything about GE rank
unfortunately Andrew Smith in there
hold circle and sword mold to charge
fast is what he said is what n MV said
well the charge of Helios those are two
and circles so I don't
I don't know D SSD SSD ESV if there's
like world events where there's like 20
people fighting a monster you charge
when you're bar on the corner left is
yellow or red
interesting I will try to look for the
cue we're currently playing on a ps4 pro
bori gaming to charge the shield you
have to press the block button during
the super burst elemental attack
animation the charge blade allows you to
attack and block in between your hits so
if you get good you can theoretically
never stop attacking damn that sounds I
see this sounds like a very that is some
spicy stuff some advanced weapon guard
points are hard - time for a new visa
fair yeah if you have no idea what
you're doing this is your second time
this is actually my first time using it
in combat I just like to mess with it in
the training mode it was like yeah this
seems a little complicated I'll start
with something simpler hmm so for kids
you have to keep attacking the monster
and there will be a color change to the
feel-feel file Oh bar so is it based on
like doing hits yeah oh yeah attack him
while he's sleeping what a bunch of
jerks oh do the vile start to glow is
that how old buddy that could be the
missing piece it's time to heal don't
watch get dodge excellent Doge don't
mind us we're just drinking a health pot
and checking out the chat yeah you need
to attack the monster - charger I like
that though you know keeping the rhythm
right like we want to get your stronger
attack it's what you have - like wow
recover store all of your charge on
shield it will make it more powerful
yeah I don't okay now it's red that's
good now I can't charge it up yeah so
you got five bars yeah
oh it's going down that's interesting
it's like Oh see yeah I'm gonna go
through these vines but not actually
tear the vines all right start to get
the hang of this weapon I'm starting to
figure it out
Ventus Blizzard says great sword all the
way also when you charge try to properly
time blocks also win charged try to we
can try to block that's you're asking a
lot I guess I guess what they're saying
is that if you charged up you can use to
block the charge
we got them make sure you yeah hey do
you know the date you will have official
review as Andrew Smith I believe it's
the 25th yep I don't know what time but
I believe it's the 25th
check out the game spots for that yeah
just to show what you can get for the
gun Lance like try it just to try it out
yeah again not a weapon he uses a lot
now like for all of them wants their
hunter pros that there seem to be in the
chat just tell us how to use it
yeah I really appreciate tell me how to
use so Dylan says charge builds with
hits when your weapon gets charged you
dump the charge into the fields that I'm
saying wrong which is those like the
jars on the bar and Belial files make
your attacks explosive until you run out
of them I see very cool
what detained John Luke dislike or like
about the game you go first I guess
since my sample size is smaller I'll
just so probably the biggest thing I
dislike is the jaemin's like throws a
lot of tutorial stuff at you pretty
early on and in a way that's just like
necessary but it probably doesn't do the
best job of explaining it and it can
feel a little overwhelming okay do you
want me to go with them dub smaller gun
or the big gun there's a couple
different ones
sorry that was what you didn't like it's
what I don't like okay so what do you
like what do I like about it I like
pretty much everything else ok let's
give a lot ok actually I mean I look
like I'm very good at it cuz I'm a
newbie but I do enjoy playing this game
quite a bit nice my sample size is
smaller I've observed more than I've
played we got reelin so nice
I I mean like I know it's Monster Hunter
and it's just how it works that you hunt
monsters for parts that you then craft
your stuff but I don't know I guess I'm
so used to like loot type games where if
you're killing a monster
you usually get something from it so
that's weird to me but I'll probably get
used to it the things I do like is I
don't people want me to go the gun Lance
I'm sorry I missed I misread that you
have the gun Lance is um like this
Lance with like a revolver gun
oh I it looks like some crazy Final
Fantasy boys night that's awesome
I went with just like the machine gun I
apologize people I was that's fine also
I remember trying the gun Lance in the
tutorial and being like yep this is too
complicated
so the Lance moves too slow for me it is
that is not my I don't think I'll ever
use that Derrick Solano what are your
favorite weapon so far again my sample
size is small so I all say switch X I
like the dual blades because I like I
like being speedy it's my favorite but
they're actually a couple weapons that I
did dig in when I was playing that I
would if I ever like made another
character just one of the switch up I
might switch to like I like the big
katana like great sword it's pretty cool
is that the one that Ben was using or
not that one no not this way not the
trick one it's just like a giant katana
that you just kind of with the typical
long sword for life series maybe that's
what it is long story yeah because the
great sword is a really big slow on it
yeah and then the long sword is like the
skinnier faster version I think that
does that crazy jump down attack me or
whatever it was also is the
kin sect weapon which is like there's
crazy like double bladed staff with
where you get like a bug that you can
shoot at people it's really weird seems
complicated but also seems kinda neat
and I sort of want to know what that
thing is all about we're being asked
what do you think to think about
refunding refunding for what yeah yeah a
lot of tips coming in for the difficult
a charged late or is it charged blade or
the gun Lance at this point the gun
Lance I'm not actually using you can see
right there yeah oh no it's the gun that
is legit like ff8 except like on a mass
on a massive scale the character creator
was more in depth right like actual game
then like what we have here there
sliders yes this just lets you mess with
the a couple of the presets yeah there's
like six head sirs and then in the
actual game you start with the presets
and then you can like customize so I
care fighters only know Ventus Oh
character creator this game we know we
got a in the in the in most cases or in
the game we would actually have to be
skinning or like Oh getting the oh dude
it's just a gun it's a Gatling gun yeah
it's very slow there's all sorts of
there's so many things where you're like
you're like an artillery at this point
here don't don't we'll be over here guys
we'll be dropping the payload hauling
your strike team
so there's something about just like
everyone else is running around with
swords and you know bone axes and then I
like got a freaking gun you're like the
tank from far away yeah there you go all
right geez
what else you got spread em Oh the S
from Contra I'll hold on oh yeah we need
to put those bullets in what that does
not look like spread ammo to me what I
would consider spread but whatever now
get the high ground
Canseco up in Eagle insect glaive Thank
You Dylan so to jump on the back oh
right yeah so people are saying it to
the high ground I believe that is a
thing where when you're using this if
you get a tactical advantage think you
get some sort of bonus when you're up
high fortunately am it's not really a
good spotting here but I do believe that
is a thing that you do more damage when
you're higher up I could be wrong che
cazzo hmm guns or swords let me think
Knapp guns
I question though how useful using yes
coos baby with ps4 sorry just answering
let's go sir how useful a range weapon
like this would be when your plane is
just single-player because it's by a lot
harder a lot harder because you know the
your allies can like pull aggro for you
to like get better shots get up high
when it's just you you're running around
so much that it's kind of tough to do a
lot of this stuff well that's the other
cool thing right like so like with the
14 weapons there's a dynamic where like
we said there's one weapon that straight
up a support weapon you know so like if
you want to play that with your friends
that's that's cool like it gives having
that variety is important I feel like
but yeah like as you mentioned as a
single-player player you probably are
looking at using something that will be
good
you know just to kill the monster if you
had to deal with them one on one Sands
you're a little pet you know but right
refunding in terms of giving digital
games back we're returning games if you
don't enjoy them um I mean I like that
steam how's that yeah we're fun thing I
think that's cool I wish that
PlayStation had something like that but
unfortunately they don't really seem to
have anything
I mean in some ways you can argue yeah
access is like almost like the rental so
that you don't have to you know like
refund your game I guess you just get
your fill if you want to guys like
interesting to think about because it's
like five bucks a month or something
dead cane the one my group of friends
have already declared our one buddy the
dedicated barred weapon guy that sucks
give him a break every now and then man
he unless he just loves playing sport if
you likes playing it make sure you oh
yeah just so we don't have to it's so
weird that it asks you a few and it
defaults to the other one neurosis is
saying guns are great in this demo until
you realize that in the full game you
spend a lot of time crafting all that
ammo right yeah so that is sort of the
payoff is that you or the trade-off is
that you have to like craft a lot of the
ammo and stuff to like efficiently use
the bows and the guns and that could be
that could be tough like I'd you know
you get a lot of resources to do it but
that is apparently the gun Lance has a
wyvern blast which feels so good to do
I'm going to bend in order to mount you
you need to attack while jumping off a
higher place that's not necessarily true
right didn't you say you could slide and
jump in a way too
yes you can jump off a higher place
there's like a slide you can do that you
can sometimes get on and then there are
certain weapons like the Kin sect clave
yeah it kind of lets you float in the
air something it has like a
like hit it into the ground like launch
yourself nice okay like springboard
yourself springboard yourself so that
one actually it's really cool for
wanting to get on space
is it time let's try it it's time I've
never fought this before come at us
chimera thing it's I imagine that's not
gonna go well there's a lot of stuff you
can craft the cool thing um that I
noticed though is like there there is a
way for you to turn on like Auto
crafting so if you know you really like
yes like a specific type of ammo or
specific type of coating as long as
you're picking up the the like herbs and
items you need
it'll just autocrat for you so that's
that's a pretty cool feature that's like
the type of stuff that you don't think
is a big deal but like that quality of
life is like you need it it's pretty
good yeah stuff like that so yeah you
could you can set it up if you were
doing a gun you could say like yes just
automatically craft blast ammo for me
anytime I have the resource to do it
stuff like that you can also buy ammo is
what Michael Mel be saying when you get
you get a fair amount of money
ooh Ben's going legit he said longsword
here we go I'm wrong go saying there are
aerial attacks and if you do enough
aerial damage you'll then mount the
monster as well yeah so that's cool is
this open world it's like not a bit more
in the traditional place like areas
right that you can guess yeah it's like
a planet make sure you eat this tables
taken
yeah as I'm Rangga says different
regions but regions are open look at
that chicken there's some sweet animate
cooking animations that I won't say that
I'll say for you guys once you play the
game that's down the road there's some
some pretty sweet stuff there's some
pretty cool visuals in this game like I
understand why they only have like I
don't have too many animations but I get
disappointed where I'm like I'm gonna
order the the veggie platter and then
they're like a giant slab of meat you
shows up at my that's not it couldn't
have gone Final Fantasy 15 about this
guy is gonna be this guy is gonna be a
hoot that's not him I like that sliding
mechanic looks cool oh it's a there is
he's angry like watching Zahn you been
know that one guys fighting him ready
Oh is he yeah oh sure Rica's fighting
him oh mine I thought we were like
discovered a monster
just so you know I saw one attack one
shot of guys so just be careful okay
that wasn't that bad so do you find
yourself staying in demon mode most of
the time or do you have to kind of like
okay and dual boys look cool but I just
I'm worried because of the short range
of it but damn Rica's going to town
though got two long swords and two dual
blades okay
digging that
can you raise the master volume Eric
everything seems a little low your voice
and the game ah
it's as high as I can make it I can
lower the game a bit but you're saying
the master so yeah I would say then
maybe try turning up your audio Alice
because there isn't much I can
personally do for you I mean I can try
hold on
Oh got a boy down what happened oh no he
painted all right so he'll come back at
some point after he gets carried to card
it away oh did you get on his back nope
but you did a nice sweet attack yeah
when I'm in demon mode I can do this
special attack where if I jump off I'll
like launch into them and then you
basically like feel like I spin down
their spine nice is the beta free yes
Ben khan kanika leo it is free on ps4
only though right now it's not on Xbox
oh no you get one shotted he definitely
has moves that I'm pretty sure we'll get
oh oh yeah he got stunned do that work
Ben pen says I can't move
oh you probably got hit by the Sun too
it's probably
there's no way he's dead right okay Oh
oh I guess the thing oh that looks like
it would one-shot you like how he has
his hand on the rock yeah get on that
rock
yeah don't get on my rock Eureka's back
is there like a limit to how many times
you can die before like just can't come
back or yes so on it's like typically
it's like three and in multiplayer to
shared that's the I think the beta beta
might happen okay because they also give
you like a really really short time
limit in the beta compared to I've
listed the game a little bit for you
guys so hopefully that works out for you
how difficult is this game it gets
harder down the road the monsters get
tougher that's for sure so yeah like you
can you could play the game like the
game has a pretty good learning curve I
feel like from one of my I've
experienced but definitely like once you
get to the endgame stuff that's like
okay you really got to you know I think
about what weapons you're using what
you're bringing to the fight you know
that's smart he's sharpening his weapon
maybe you should do that
see note the monsters don't actually
have health bars like on screen you'll
just notice like actual damage on them
or like lack of body parts sometimes
like subs orcs are trying to like cut
his tail off right now
that's been he's he's trying to ride
that near Gigante oh he just going back
and forth on the back and the tail close
Oh is he staggered go down get beaten up
bro
yeah I play this game completely new if
you just pick one of the sort of the
more basic like beginner weapons that
aren't too complicated and you will I
think the game in the nice I don't think
it is as tough a learning curve
improvements in this version watch out
Ventus saying that the difficulty
depends on the monster the amount of
hunters you have in the group and the
equipment you're using yep having sense
they can't that person can't wait till
they to see if they have G rank they're
just people this gear Gantt a is five
chaos before game over and fifteen
minutes to complete thank you the
ultimate Tetris so we've had like two
chaos
oh boy
you need to keep going ham just kidding
don't do that there is multiplayer
online up and even in the beta there is
we're playing with three other players
right now one of which we know and two
that we don't they just bite cute for
the houses oh no all right so that's
three we got two more oh that's not good
yep there's the one shot oh they made it
too and we lost yeah I try again
let's try again damn tie you could tell
it was like one of those Dark Souls
moves where it's just like he's doing
something bad and I think you're like
stuck in that narrow ass lane so it's
like do you are there like like slight
invulnerability frames when you're
dodging there like if you had dodged
that perfectly when he flies by do you
think you would have lived maybe okay
maybe it's really easy to get stunned in
an animation too dang that yeah that's
tough can you have multiple characters I
yeah you're gonna up to three character
sweet like do you gain a lot more skills
as you're crafting new weapons like or
is it pretty much the same like you're
the list of moves you're doing that is
always the same so you're just adding
damage and started reading like bonus
like modifiers like this one does fire
damage I got stuff that one shot looks
scary yeah let's do it guys had this
feeling it was coming you know if I
don't have friends can I still finish
all the contents hello yes yep I've been
playing the majority of my experience
nice I'm raga Rangga sorry not like the
super endgame stuff yeah yeah but the
story the 30 hours or so story that I
had mentioned yeah I'm wrong I'm wrong
uh says I think there are iframes okay
so like if you time it right then that's
we might be able to I believe they're
our friends yeah but it's like this like
I don't I hate using Dark Souls as well
like that and I'll be all for examples
but um it's like it's when you panic and
you do it a little early and you're like
yeah I take it for is the max team size
I think so hopefully it's your destiny
boys Bob there's in six of you total
split up into two groups of three
apparently oh god I can't say this guy's
names I don't call um BD says there's a
skill that gives you more iframes on
your evade oh cool oh really
that's cool that's awesome PC is late
2018 I think you had said maybe August
but I don't know if that's do you know
if that's up for sure I don't know
that's not sure a heavy bogans special
animal is pretty strong and refills
pretty fast thank you the ultimate
Tetris probably won't be experimenting
with weapons against mr. near gorg ante
over here but uh possibly we have time
we can mess around with another weapon
but my guess is for the next 15 minutes
probably fighting this boy just this guy
right here yeah another like what we're
hoping to kill him here but you know if
we don't we'll give it maybe one more go
after that and then Oh Riko switching
weapons when he went great sword I don't
I don't know that's like total like
polar opposite of the weapon he just he
was just using but whatever he's easy to
avoid so to go to the great sword is
like oh no man you're going from like
doing 100-yard dash to maybe running a
mile
or two and even Wow been done even using
the longsword what is going on here Ben
is using the switch ax I think oh god
he's he's taking the damage though run
Ben do the monsters get easier to kill
if you play alone I think they scale
right so oh but someone else is saying
it's easier with people I mean like I
can see the pros and cons but they're
like pros and cons where it's like you
know you're it's a shared pool of like
lives yeah
a party member where one person's just
like fumbling all the time and I'm yeah
yeah
so as it really depends on rangas
mentioned good point here is that the
monster gets more help with more players
so yes it's easier solo but you're also
the only one damaging him then at that
point and I also feel like in these kind
of games where there's like a boss and
you have multiple people fighting the
boss he kind of like targets certain
people right so it gives you the ability
or freedom to do something else it's
easy
Wow range weapons become a little bit
more viable because oh he has a ranged
attack yes it is open beta onder's goo
wants you to get closer to the mic or
come flatter me yeah you're good no
don't worry
he's fighting right now ah eh - I would
say most of the weapons are probably
viable solo but some are gonna
definitely be harder than others like I
wouldn't use the support weapon probably
solo and maybe some of the guns would
probably be pretty tough solo
potentially I don't know good eating it
one shots that's fine oh there's that
there's that arranged attack
2d geek saying rx gaming said there
won't be a G rank until later paid dlc
like in the japanese versions of the
game who knows but yeah i I trust our ex
used to play a bunch of destiny and
divisions like that so I think has a
bunch of like weapon guides - having
watched in the window
are we gonna do like a which weapons
right for you I believe or something of
that something like that okay cuz I'd
like to know probably had to land it on
Ben's knowledge there though right she
seems to have a better handle on the
weapons than we do I like how the other
monsters help you out sometimes the most
I would do is just like yeah yeah or you
just try to draw like relations to other
dudes like if you liked playing support
and you have a group you maybe you want
to plays Abad and also still attack it
looks like this huge like you like you
said it's like bagpipes which sounds
like a nag pipe i missed something here
from tip inator but someone's answering
his question so that's good sorry if i'm
missing some questions i'm trying to
read them as oh good maybe I should use
my ID of eco disturb us says jellyfish
some sense onin I'm a big souls and
Monster Hunter fan I mostly played these
two series I love the struggle as you
first take on a monster and how you
learn to crap on them after a few fights
and as the soul games as Souls it's a
game like that i guess it is it's
totally got that same satisfaction
I definitely am enjoying myself with
this game guys could you make a rough
approximation or the map sizes I'd have
to defer that to John Wow they're all
similar so each maps about similar size
to each other which is nice to them
which is nice like multiple layers Oh
someone somebody aggro him as far as
size goes I don't really I'm sure ocj
fans back they said they removed gunner
armor in the world world everyone uses
the same armor guess that must be
something related to a better question
do you think this game would be good for
a destiny player ask Mike Jenkins huh
funny you asked that huh I want to say
yes I would say yeah if the thing you
like about destiny is the sort of like
I'm gonna play with friends we're gonna
do our daily like you know yeah kill a
monster
here we go it's so stylish destiny
absolutely obviously the combat yeah not
an FPS well you can make it it kind of
it kind of if you like the shooting of
destiny that was a social aspect
I would say yeah good for problem
quarters like K is long and someone said
there are things people like about
destiny yeah of course I think there's
some stuff in there like from destiny
one maybe like later in Destiny one that
people don't think about that are
actually they're like pretty pretty
solid things they just want a game to
like I don't have friends yeah like I
don't think outside of like a
traditional MMORPG any other game has
probably done a better job of like that
social gaming experience but I guess you
could argue then that the game is like a
platformer which people hate whatever
I'm looking for I don't know I'm torn Oh
doing that charge I'm really torn I cuz
Dragon Ball fighters and Monster Hunter
comes out the same day and I know
Monster Hunter is gonna be like this
game that you have to spend a lot of
hours in so I just don't know I haven't
decided yet
oh but this is cool like I I don't know
if there was ever gonna be a monster
hunter game to get me in it would be
this one because it's on PlayStation I
was never gonna play on handheld
try to convince me multiple times get on
- yes dan Persky our first game that's
not bad
we're doing a lot better than the last
time I think everyone's learned I could
put a bed and just try to mount him I
think and it didn't work
get poisoned I should be using more
these like powdered stuff with the demon
powder is pretty good
the crits like a mist when you're in
that mist you like do more damage wait
is a wreck seen here I don't think he's
in here I think someone just mentioned
his name oh no he isn't here
what's up 4x thanks for stopping by yeah
everyone saying hello to him it's like
someone caught somebody said my name
someone rang
do they have matchmaking for players or
do you need to invite friends
I would yeah I mean we we have two
people in here that aren't that we don't
know at all so I would assume if it's in
beta it's got to be in the floor there's
matchmaking you can basically create a
server that'll be open and then you can
just match make and join a server that
is open so these people just brand them
outside of Penn and so the two people
just randomly join my game so yeah if
you are the kind of person who's like I
just want to play with some people you
can totally be on this game oh
five minutes always tails off though I
didn't even see that happen I mean too
involved in looking at shot this whole
time okay
well I mean the good news is you guys
only have one down it's just like are
you guys gonna be able to kill him in
five minutes is the the real question
you guys at this point
everyone is dazed that thinks that
wasn't the one shot I don't think no
zort did he die
oh he's after zort
no he smells blood
oh shoot no I'm good maybe there's
there's the second thing or a second
cart while you sit over here
don't sweat it it's fine only give you
the warning on time at like there's not
like an actual indicator huh right there
okay it's not very much but you're on
like Phase three though right like
whatever that man I don't take that with
a grain of salt ions oh this guy's
charging the never fought those guys I
really would know get smacked
oh that's that's a one shot yep told you
I told you that was the one shot yeah I
could tell he was up in this up in the
sky damn it sucks we need ben's deeps
that's crazy that some guy killed him in
four minutes or something like almost 5
minutes probably a monster under prowl
yeah
streaming this earlier today this boss
is a beast as a spread beam attack yeah
where can you get new weapons s monster
card game lol you have to craft them
well in the innocent in the when the
game comes out you're gonna have to
craft them you get the kind of cheezer's
your starting weapon though yep
pretty cool and in the beta if you want
to mess around with just the weapons to
figure out what you want to use for the
when the game actually comes out there's
like a little training ground that you
can use all the different weapons and
like learn the different combos with
them get a feel for them also you could
just you know get into the ps4 beta if
you have his his bore and you know go
hunt some monsters try out the different
weapons come back knocked out of my
animation oh really I thought you're
about to jump on no I was about to I was
about to do a cool thing he is limping
he's he's going home we gotta go get her
to God like I'm gonna nap I'm gonna go
take a nap I don't know if we can do
this time but you got to believe your
whole team's like come on paralyzed
oh don't get hit by the one shot I think
you can solo this if you are really good
protip smack monster don't get hit yeah
that's technically true oh did you guys
lose lose I'll be lost lost alright give
it you can give it one more go that'll
be the last time you got close there so
third time's a charm he was very close
to is what uh we had a minute left I
think if you didn't die there you guys
might have been able to kill him but it
just depends on how much damage you guys
could have did I supposed but man you
barely got hit twos like the his wing I
think that got you third time's a charm
that's right Phil and Spencers their
time is a charm hopefully hopefully
because that's all the time or all the
times he's gonna get so yeah pretty fun
stuff thank you guys all for tuning in
to our final hunt Monster Hunter World
beta currently on the Playstations so if
you want to check that out yourself you
got a Playstation it's up and available
till the 22nd
- I think a.m. UTC you got Tom kook
alright so yeah check that out the
releases next week as mentioned both of
us pretty much have never played a
monster hunter game previously so I
couldn't answer that question ultimate
Tetris this is that game that's gonna
has gotten John Luke in and probably
gonna get hopefully oust me in but
haven't decided yet
[Music]
are you guys gonna open a room so some
viewers can join or just randoms rip to
the Fallen we're just trying to see if
we can kill New Yorker Gant and we're
almost gonna wrap up the stream here so
sorry that we didn't do any of you er
matches but I think John Luke and been
going forward after Monster Hunter
actually comes out will probably be
trying to do you know once a week
Monster Hunter world stuff so maybe then
they can get a viewer to in to kind of
you know like some hunts so stay tuned
to that obviously yeah happy to open
that up to other people yeah community
who want to hunt some monsters with us
so apparently the weak spots of the New
York gig ante or the front arms tail and
the head okay
heads a bit tough yeah we can do the
front the front arms we chopped the tail
off last time or someone chopped the
tail off
so we serves that dual blade tips
Archdemon miller actually don't know
about this by landing attacks while in
demon mode and maxing out the demon
gauge there are some special attacks
only available in this mode oh okay time
to go it's called get an eat eat on nice
works Rams that you were able to solo
mister neared you're dancing nice
jailbreak junk respect to Capcom I don't
see EA being creative ever anymore they
don't make the games though they just
published I guess that's true but like
the games that I think of that like I
want to be good like anthem at games and
shrubs I think Sam titanfall 3 not
talking don't want to go there we're
having a positive stream today let's
just let's just enjoy the fact that we
have a sweet game like Monster Hunter
world coming out and sweet the head
requires piercing damage to the horn
reflecting on even great green sharpness
okay thank you deadly Aquila so don't
aim for the head probably
getting the Ben's gonna Ben is just
mixing it up
screw it gone let's do it Oh Rica just
David don't die right away man did he
did Rica switch weapons to or is he
still walking the great sword
remember front to two feet if you can is
obviously scary cuz it ain't easy
and ram sanchez says the best time he
had on your garage solo was a 21 with
his switch axe nice but the best time
was 348 with a heavy boga so man there's
some Monster Hunter pros out there which
is awesome I kind of want to watch I
want to watch some of these like
speedrun kills just to see what they're
doing when is cyberpunk 2077 coming out
who knows well let's just let's just get
a subtype of anything but that one
trailer and that's already a victory and
they got verified
we got verified and they tweeted which
is like you know people low as a rumor
on reddit that it's gonna be a 320 s
this year 2018 we'll see who knows we're
convinced I don't know why I made that
noise I think I made you a 12 for days
there's no loot boxes in anthem right or
was that from as an analyst no no an
anthem I can't remember if I was an
analyst saying that or not but that was
an analyst I think they gotta be crazy
if they're gonna try to put these boxes
in like it anyways I don't want why are
we talking about that we said we weren't
work sorry what were you saying about
you and Jake you were so sure we were we
were convinced that of the game awards
was gonna have a cyber Punk and oh no
Ben's out how goes the hunt ask a Rex
it's not going so hot but it's fun
nonetheless Ben died
how did he die with the gun charge
thanks for stopping by Rex yes
so someone was I forgot I think those
Rams were saying you got to be
aggressive with those horns but I don't
know if you're gonna be able to you need
piercing damage is this an MMORPG No
yeah so it was a just so we know it's a
Japanese person that did it with the
heavy bow gun so shout out to that
whoever that guy
well it's market order is huge in yeah
so this has got to be like awesome for
them probably well the whole reason
monster on our ears was success yeah I
don't know that's fair actually until it
comes out on the switch like a bigger
way yeah so good so one shot
I was watching of one of the like
original Monster Hunter like CG videos
and just like seeing like wow this looks
better than that
like ps2 CG video is like pretty cool
like wow like it's amazing we're getting
a monster and actually like it looks
this good if not better oh I'll check
that out later Rams Sanchez he says it's
HPG on YouTube nice uh yes you can party
up with your friends to play this game
green em or you can match make as well
maybe it's no you don't need projectile
a piercing damage that's only for
projectile weapons I think is what you
trying to say
yeah there's been my okay TMC collection
is a good shot that's it in like two
months its March I was I was looking at
the games that are coming on like the
next couple months and outside of like
this and Dragon Ball fighters like it's
gonna be pretty sparse until like Far
Cry 5 like in terms of like big games
that aren't like you know Bayonetta on
switch yeah I think that war is pretty
light from what I recall there I mean
there are some games coming out but
they're not like big notable like Triple
A games that's true that issue bayonetta
on switch and Bayonetta 2 on switches
also February and there was a there's
like a tack on Titan yeah apparently I
think dynasty warriors comes out and
apparently that's gonna be like pretty
different compared to the old oil so
we'll see run been ok or get smacked
he's like I got a big gun I can't
[Music]
teamwork seems to be the key here yeah
oh this is this is good this is good
stuff right now
I'm liking what I'm seeing here we're
learning that would frustrate the hell
out of me that the short range and that
Oh
get smacked yeah where you're just like
Oh die in one shot it's okay
whoo that that hurt a lot whatever the
hell that was
I'm out of the monster awesome
incredible weird and Kroy a ball cruel
maybe he has some remapped that'd be
pretty sweet watch can tip firm a speed
runs that I learned charge way nice okay
thanks
videos and you like brings down every
monster and weapon he seemed pretty
pretty cool
Oh code beam what is that that's yeah
that's this year for sure okay so the
one thing that makes me a little bit
skeptical skeptical about that game even
though it's like what I would want I
love anime and I like to love Dark Souls
is that it seems like unless I'm
mistaken it seems like you always have
like one of those partner AI people with
you which like defeats the whole purpose
of those games for me for me personally
because it's like they get distracted
right the AI gets distracted and doesn't
know who to pick sometimes I know it'll
pick like you know your helper and it's
like well why am I afraid the best thing
is to paralyze you know dead though
right you're good but that fight isn't
yeah
get knives
oh no no we got a faint no oh I did it
no I'm reading Chad I'm not the one
playing yellow fish and then anything
you guys have that I need to go I pass
it on to John Luke who is who is playing
this is Monster Hunter not Dark Souls
that's true karma we were just talking
about code being which is why ya chop
that tail hey hey are you doing rock for
friends here yeah Dragon Ball fighters
next week something good gonna be sweet
I'm playing that I was looking finally
buying a new fight stick yeah you're
probably gonna need one for that I stall
the legacy I'm just gonna controller
that I'll figure it out
the only way to beat this monster is to
be agile and aggressive as him while
striking where the spikes are at good to
know did he get stuck in the ant hill
things frames I think I feel like we're
behind compared to last time the same
I don't know where everyone else is yeah
so we have five minutes and his tail is
not even off which is Wow mildly
technically don't know I know but it's
just like a nice little indicator that
you guys realize in my opinion doing
better but who knows I could be wrong
this is good he just needs to stay here
Oh seems like Benny's high up somewhere
or higher up yeah he's definitely on the
hill or so we got to range boy
yeah ones a ones been using the boat oh
he figured out Ben's tactics Oh Ben
looks like he's in a little bit of
trouble Brian yeah it kind of leads it
doesn't I don't know if it necessarily
recoups but it'll go to sell like the
net the next area is it staggers away
yeah so eventually once it's like
limping limping it will go back
hit him hit him shoot that tail off
yes if spikes go black then you're gonna
bounce often and lay low damage and only
meander Gant a can actually remove the
black spikes from himself with that dive
that he doesn't do air oh wow that is
some complexity there oh no Rica I don't
think that's gonna be the problem I
think that your lack of time is going to
be oh here we go here we go here we go
okay so I think yeah I think you're on
to deaths maybe three so as long as your
team doesn't have some crazy big one
shot I think you might be able to do
this yeah come back here
oh yeah that's great he's stunned you
seen stars yeah oh we got him think so
okay oh there goes his tail the tail
pick it up just kidding I know you can
what does he do he Blair I'm just hiding
in the corner crying oh my goodness how
much can customize your character in
terms of looks there's a good amount
sucks
I can't even he says we have like three
deaths what the hell all right well we
appreciate everyone tuning in to today's
Monster Hunter World beta we got the
time for it - I know no you only have 20
seconds left right now it said we were
12 or do so you had three like 220 yeah
we had about like 222 times it's out on
PlayStation 4 only but you can play it
it's open beta so check it out if you
guys want to the game comes out next
week the 26th I believe our review will
be up on the 25th yep a lot of stuff
from RN will be coming out slowly uh you
know across those days and we'll be
streaming it of course Thank You Jon
link for playing absolutely and yeah
come back next Monday when we stream
again at 11:00 a.m. appreciate everyone
stopping by and have a good weekend have
a good weekend guys things been for
dying just kidding
[Music]